new in theaters this weekend escape room
and don't forget the Golden Globes what
will you watch this is your weekend
ticket
[Music]
dear Khalil to escape this episode of
weekend ticket you must solve a series
of puzzles the first puzzle
what movie comes out this weekend escape
room the escape room is a psychological
thriller about a group of strangers who
find themselves in one of those puzzle
rooms we should look for clues what are
we looking for here anything that looks
like a puzzle or code it looks like an
oven dial
well that's creepy as hell
are they there who brought them there oh
and this escape room can kill you this
movie is for you if you like
psychological puzzle horror like saw
watching more scary movies as part of
your new fears resolution or you like
making friends out of strangers in
unique ways also airing this weekend the
Golden Globes 2018 was such a good year
there are so many nominations to mention
a star is born
Black Panther Bohemian Rhapsody crazy
rich Asians Mary Poppins should I name
them all or should I just tell them go
to fandango.com
ok see more at fandango.com well that is
your weekend ticket what will you see
check back next week to see if a dog
finds his way home and if I couldn't
find my way out of this Oh a clue
egg
[Music]
[Music]